let's actually listen to now naomi long
of the alliance party who's uh now
addressing uh the press conference again
flash photography continues back to
scrutinizing ministers back to doing the
things that the assembly can do and yet
despite the fact that the vast majority
of people in northern ireland voted for
parties that wanted to return to
government and wanted to see the
assembly work and despite the fact that
even those who voted for the dup gave
them no mandate to block a return to the
assembly
we have found ourselves in that
situation today but whilst this is a sad
day for the people of northern ireland
it is a shameful day for the dup
today the dup came to stormont signed
the register
took their salaries but refused to take
their seats and do the work to earn it i
don't think that that is ever acceptable
but it is particularly unacceptable when
people in our constituencies are
struggling to feed their families
struggling to hate their homes worried
for their futures and it puts all of us
as politicians
in a place which is embarrassing yet
again where we want to serve the public
but are prevented from doing so
make no mistake the gulf between those
who got up today in the chamber and
bemoaned the cost of food in marx and
spencers and those who i represent who
get their food from food banks and it
just shows the detachment there is
between some people who come to this
chamber interested only in their party
self-interest and those of us who
actually come here to serve
i am appalled that we could not even
challenge the person who made this
decision because having been returned as
an mla only a week ago
he has disappeared off to his safety net
in parliament to the comfy green benches
rather than come here and do the job
that only a week ago he promised people
he would do
so this is a shameful day for the dup
but despite all of that we are here
ready to work
we may not be able to go into the
chamber and do the work as we intended
but we will be in our constituencies
working for the people who elected us i
will be in my ministerial office working
for the people who elected me and we
will continue to do all that we can
to make life better for the people of
northern ireland irrespective of those
who have nothing to offer but more drama
more division and more disruption it is
now time for them to call this to a
close allow us to get a speaker allow us
to move on and allow northern ireland to
move forward
thank you
naomi long there the alliance party also
saying that the people of northern
ireland in her opinion voted for parties
that wanted to see a an executive formed
uh following of course those comments we
just uh summarized from michelle o'neill
of sinn fein our senior island
correspondent david blevins
is is available to react with me now and
and david uh more of the same i guess uh
from both the alliance party but but
importantly as well from sinn fein
moments earlier
i think the word of the day is
frustration clearly that is what sinn
fein is expressing this was an historic
election for them the party overtaking
unionism for the very first time for the
for the first time in northern ireland's
history in fact there is an irish
nationalist first minister elect and
michelle o'neill is very keen to assume
that office and to get government up and
running again also deep frustration
there being expressed by naomi long her
party did exceptionally well in the
election they doubled their
representation in the stormwind assembly
indicating a shift to the middle ground
that more and more people are desiring a
different kind of politics here she's
also expressing her frustration that she
couldn't um challenge sir jeffrey
donaldson himself over this decision in
the house because of course he hasn't
taken his seat here yet he's remaining
as an mp at westminster until the issue
of the protocol is resolved but of
course for the dup it's a question of
frustration as well they've run out of
patience with the uk government over
that brexit border in the irish sea and
they say it's time for action not words
and until they get some action then they
say that they're not prepared to elect a
speaker and see the assembly functioning
or to become part of a power sharing
government so immense pressure now on
the prime minister he's got to make a
difficult decision
about how to resolve this and as you
heard from michelle o'neill she expects
boris johnson to be in northern ireland
next week along with the taoiseach the
irish prime minister michael martin
david blevins uh outside sermon thank
you